[音楽]
8完全に1億円が家にあります日本銀行は
ですね日本近郊から応募してきました本当
に1億円をおろせると思ってなかった
まあまあ自分でてほんの冗談抜きで今回
ネタじゃない for new 直掩です
ものです
北
金持ちで前回僕の誕生日14feb 僕の
誕生日に金持ち宇宙ば聞かれた髪の毛が
無菌とクローンに分かれて変な人がいるん
ですけどあの人に誕生日プレゼントもナン
デスのを回収しようと思いまして今回光
さんのためですね
1億円
僕の交差からバーン下ろしてこれを光さん
にあげませあげませんその判断に簡単に
そのあげませんあげないんですけども
やっぱり惹かれさんで言えばお金の
イメージお金が好きなイメージが強いので
持ったらさんがタダで彫金あげるなんて本
ていない
氷上さんの開始次第ではあると思います光
さんが来年の僕の誕生日に高いものをくれ
たらひょっとしたら俺は胃腸炎を上げるか
も知れませんけど前回僕の単純にヴィトン
のヴィトンの最高セットくれたんですけど
これもなかなか高いものだったんで中堅と
は行きませんけども光さんはやっぱりお金
が好きなんで光さんが欲しい部分
hikage 3がつかめる分だけ族園の
中からあげようかなと思いまして1億円
つかみ取りを1回だけさせてあげたいと
思います studio を手配しました
1億円持っていどせたらマジで殺すかつ
あるんですよ飛空やっちゃえば1お弁当に
入るんで計 b もしっかり準備してこの
1億人のプールにばらまいてあるさんを
だいぶさせて5掴み取り
あるさんに借りの執着心があればあるほど
たくさんのお金がつ食べるのではない
でしょうか誰なん
僕からのプレゼントは
金です
[音楽]
ん
んうぃーん
[音楽]
me
に直面
持ってきました
ちょっと怖かったんで警備員の方の報告を
いただいて安全に1億円 stage まで
運ぶことができました
[音楽]
普通良きで1億円でございますしでは早速
いっ直演ずるに入れていきたいとおもい
ます
奪い良いん
だってこれで1000万ですうわーこえー
なんと日本近郊月なんだよ
一つは100万でしょこれ
あっ一面が悪いことする気持ちになるなぁ
いただきますよ
[音楽]
ああああああ
やばいそれは取られたらまずいわん
なああああああダメなぜこれけっこうある
ね
ううすげー閉部稽古としてるよよかった
高い2件ちょっと足りないと思ってたんだ
よバットニットとしては通って世界と
やっぱりバラ charset 多いの
俺めっちゃ3倍は修理ですねあっっ
取ってってって言ったらいいのだってこれ
からあとはもう何者がゲットみたらなんだ
ん
持っていた
という気で実を喰えのプールってきました
めっちゃ悪い奴に見えますね僕べきで
1万円札だけだとちょっとアレなんで
1億800万円はんぺん5万円分千円札と
5000社と落ちるダメさせてもらいまし
たこれで果たして士和さんは誕生日にどれ
だけ使うことができるでしょうか
パパ書かれています
なんだと思います
貴家さんお誕生日おめでとうございます
[音楽]
がちな彼
ミカサえっ
1億円準備しました
担当におめでとうございます類語今から
1億円チャレンジに
[音楽]
ヒアロスはこれ
ロサンぬ
[音楽]
深緑ですっどうぞ八日市から3枚阿部剛
そこだね
pou
dou
[拍手]
dou円盤が持っていかれませんあるん
[笑い]
ブーブー脱で誘っちゃいけないあの
クレーン泥湯を塗ってるライブに行って俺
がガチで political さぞ
ufoキャッチャーですなるほどねっデジ
頑張ったと一発入った一つ一つずきでーす
そう結構行く度おこさと思いましたやす
もういいんですいい
でとって戻るんですかここに入れる具
で僕今日
30社が3000万7な
33,000前に押しできるでしようと
思っても全力であることが大事だと思って
始めたこういう人間から
全落通りに高価なお願いしますじゃあ
するされるという
[音楽]
さあというわけで早速光さんの誕生日
プレゼントの準備が整いました今の心境
いかがでしょうと回ってますよね
戸惑いしかない唐樋間取りですが光る様を
関連は
ほしいまあ一つ言っておきたいのは
10億円持ってても1兆円ほしい
できれば個性となく思ってる3競技が
欲しいそうですね r 2個しかありませ
んがもちろん素敵な誕生日してください
ロスあれ big moon そう ok
阿部さん大丈夫ですかー
ん
もちろん
でこれ操作するの僕ですを感じませんね
これじゃさあ
ましたなぜいてあげてみますねー
[音楽]
[拍手]
がんばれん
俺はぁ本だけで
テソンで油すぎ
大丈夫かあるを生かしれれば前いきますよ
もう1回三国で全然ボタンで4位だして
くださいねよ
まあはさらに多くなる春ライターグル下げ
たいこの高さ故は受けておきますか言って
持った
[拍手]
ありません
ここのものをなぁこれだけで雇用社員だよ
t up ですサイバーこの読み込んない
んですよえっ高さとだもいいですか
ていた頃マット巻いたよ起き酒月ん
ません
たユーザを形が見えてきました
すごいでこの光景 pot 利用
キャッチャー先にルーフを開くよる利用減
チェッカー ch フィー線日本なのに
この後当局のかなおこのねこれも
ビールですから心の準備は ok ok
もちろんだし日本が全部取り豪華な弾ける
なえっ
いきますよん
ok 結構面白い
もうすごい
これでもさ
多分
[音楽]
oo 相撲
本能リリー
ノーズ
もなおこの本
もう一度梅がもちろんもしれませんあー
まぁこんなもんからました一家た人ができ
てみて一回一回通り神秘1回今季に入って
ペンライト振っ
どんぐらいけっこ1夏まって結構だけ
するっ
やばいさあこれもツンがムズイ彼のこの他
施設は無馬場も来るからたちの人が店脈
から
単純にめでとうございました無職で全然
トレーニングを起こしました女盗賊団
感じるじゃん人も頭下げてみますいやもう
ちょっとなあコレだ
またとってまー坊香川だが動画でに思うよ
ドロスちっ快速動画の殺すぞ
すべて腹巻ず何人磨崖仏9分
これしかない
これ
いきますよああもうこれが限界
これ全開といきますよ
イケてる人は御礼
[拍手]
[音楽]
voodooんだ
ちょっとでやばい
神戸9分かはぁ
登場デュエリスト
goo
me
8倍パイっしょ大
ほいった if いただきますよね
やっぱ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーバーまあ引いちゃって行っちゃった
中丸そうなんです直に誕生日を喜んでいい
のかわからん line にきちゃって
るっていうやばいずになってや何かまずい
もないですからから誕生日ですからもう
大丈夫
cf
そんな欲しかったんで僕は何なのでそして
そうでせいかせいか言ったところ大正解で
だからが良かったら言え金額が先ほどお
会計が終わったんですけどもしっかりと
数えさせていただきましたちょっとながら
様子を炊いて大丈夫大丈夫じゃないですよ
タロ
スよてひゃれさんが獲得した金額前検察が
1495枚5千円札が11032 q マイ
ホセ
1万円札
乗船288ないで
合計金額5,000円7万円
[音楽]
かぶったあー
じゃあね大丈夫工場これ
大丈夫僕とりなすっ
これがいいんですよねうちられないけど
大丈夫か約5000万円です版なんですよ
かなるのに半分ね
[音楽]
アリア所は無罪を続けておりますよはいん
当時金の使い道とか決まってますか
使い道は
一市長との youtube の木閣議で
使いたいっ
ですかこれ6人を懐を肥やすている
ちょっとおかしい
そうだから一市長と木の間50007万円
を使って何かやりたいな
頃からユーチューバーじゃないですかそれ
さあ逆それが故に思ったこれこれこそ有名
だけど猫の毛それはすぐあり方です僕的に
はもうだから触れ金銭の受け渡しはまあ
一旦なしで羽根ショット撮る
youtube の企画にこれを使って
下さ5000万ねぇ何かするっ男女たち
またで出てきてないけどまぁそれをは部
youtube に残して視聴者に負担し
てもらいたいと悪くない5000万も何か
に使いましょう
本当ですか
もちろんヌーはこれをいきなりその貯金
たい r スポロス言い渡し確認
ヌード本当にお誕生日でございまーす
[音楽]
padi オープン
直後あった